ah
[Música]
si había preguntas que es moralista
favorito el del tiempo actual
contemporáneo yo te diría que donald
trump
jm ya bájate del escenario y por favor
digo del tiempo actual porque el
muralismo ha acompañado a las
comunidades a través de la historia y
este generado un impacto positivo
y a veces como que no tanto no
las fotos las políticas que nos maman
yo vengo mexicali
una ciudad vecina de eeuu donde hace un
calor de a madres en el que toda mi vida
crecí viendo el muro que divide los dos
países para mí no es nada nuevo
simplemente es algo más alto y por el
acceso que tenemos a los medios y a
internet es mucho más popular pero es
pura propaganda
el muro de agua digital y el ritmo de
vida de todo sigue igual no podemos
evitar que pasar
tenemos esta pared mamá lona dos metros
más alta pero te juro que es lo mismo
tenemos que formar puentes para
recuperar la unión que nos hace falta y
estos puentes solo los vamos a lograr si
vamos a este tema un poquito más allá de
un de una
quejado de una plática informal
tenemos que manifestarnos
pero no de forma violenta
no de forma autoritaria no bloqueando
las calles por un día una semana como
las mamás chingarse entre ustedes
tenemos que crear una revolución por
medio del arte
tenemos que recuperar la calle que ya
era nuestra
hay muchos muros grises allá afuera
tenemos que borrar ese filtro sepia que
nos pone en las películas gringas
tenemos que hacer una revolución por la
cual la gente se identifique
estoy seguro de que todos podemos
interpretar algo propio de esta de esta
obra
de esta otra el arte es una
manifestación pura de la actividad
humana
es un elemento esencial en el desarrollo
y la evolución del hombre
pablo picasso dijo que después de
altamira pura decadencia
quién hubiera pensado que pablo picasso
se iba a sentir insignificante tras ver
estos muros en altamira españa'
la persona personas hombre o mujer de
las cavernas que algo que hayan hecho
esta pintura lo habrán hecho por
satisfacción personal eso no lo podemos
saber pero si sabemos el impacto que
causó si sabemos que 15 mil años después
impacto de esa forma a una figura como
pablo picasso
el arte genera identidad
todos nos podemos describir con fotos
con libros con películas con música
cuando empieza tu canción en la pena que
es lo primero que gritas güey mi canción
es tuya uy ya no le pertenece a juan
gabriel valdés miguel ya es tuya
hay comunidades como la huichol que
identificamos por sus patrones únicos
en tijuana reconocemos al burro pintado
de cebra con un elemento turístico de
esa ciudad
y con los que sin verlos por completo
sabemos de dónde son y a quién le
pertenecen
yo a mexicalli lo identificó por su
calorón y la comida china pero
también por su nombre lo que cuando se
me presentó la oportunidad armamos este
mural
esta actividad genera ninguna adicción
al muro o más bien una adicción a ver
qué tan lejos puede llegar pues en una
ciudad con sed de identidad como
mexicalli la gente solo ex dueño de él y
lo volvió suyo
quiero recalcar que no todos los muros
nos separan
a veces con que no compartamos la misma
opinión de la persona que tenemos a un
lado queremos una barrera
es una clase de muro que nadie puede
pintar
por eso el muralismo tiene que ser tan
impactante tan cabrón y llegarte tan al
fondo como para que la pintura se
transforme en una idea
muchas gracias subestimamos el impacto
de nuestras creaciones
a veces algo de tu día a día puede
cambiarle la vida a otra persona de
formas en las que no te esperas
una vez yo venía saliendo de una clase
de diseño con mi ilustrar favorito el
gil y pollo nos puso un ejercicio a
contrarreloj y en una hora teníamos que
hacer un póster no y yo me lo entenderá
ipad con el dedo
terminé fui uno de los primeros en
terminar y al final de la clase su
retroalimentación y su crítica me
estimuló tanto que yo estaba súper
contento estaba volando o sea imagínate
tú artista favorito
dándote una crítica no fue ni buena ni
fue mala simplemente me puso atención y
fue un póster y yo me lo gané
weinman es el póster de hill así en el
metro con mi póster lloviendo todos
todos tenían sujeto está pero iba con el
póster
estaba en ermita esperando el metro está
todo llena de gente y se me acerca un
bato así como del lado
y te puedo hacer una pregunta yo dije y
me van a saltar en frente de todos
porque
[Música]
y dije vas suelta
y mi hijo vale la pena seguir viviendo
en que pedo me queda este drogado
que es mejor
dadme la más fácil
yo estaba tan contento con el póster de
la mano que le dije sí vale vale la pena
vale la pena seguir viviendo yo basado
en mi buen día no todos tenemos buenos y
malos días pero yo lo hace en un momento
en esa vibra de ese día
él me dijo que acababa de perder a su
esposa en un accidente de taxi
justo esa mañana y su hija de seis meses
estaba muriendo el hospital lo acababan
de despedir
el único dinero que tenía en los 800
pesos que le habían dado por su celular
si yo no respondía bien la respuesta el
vato iba a brincar de las vías
yo no soy psicólogo de nada yo no soy
experto en nada
yo soy arquitecto y artista sabes
pero esa vibra esa felicidad
qué causó en mí haber hecho el ejercicio
bien
y que el que mi artista favorito tuviera
las ganas de hacer bien su chamba
me dio a mí esa energía para quedarme
con él
para pedir dos horas dinero en el metro
para enfrentar el problema que tenía
lo hice reír con las pendejadas que me
salían de la boca y creo que lo más
importante que yo me quedo con eso es
que le hice saber que él no estaba solo
él no estaba solo en medio de ese
cientos de personas
imagínate cuántos muros se habrá topado
antes de toparse con un que trae
un póster y que tiene una sonrisa en la
cara
es de este impacto del que les hablo
el mismo impacto que hacen del muro de
donald trump un nuevo punto de
decadencia pero también se convierte en
un nuevo punto de partida este elemento
colosal tributo al racismo y al rechazo
se convierte en un canvas en blanco
donde miles y miles de artistas van a ir
a plasmar su arte van a dejar una parte
de ellos en él van a hacer lo suyo
van a causar un impacto para ellos
mismos y para todos los demás
se va a convertir en una obra en
colaboración involuntaria
la gente va a pasar y va a preguntar hoy
ese muro de quienes nadie va a saber
nadie va a saber si es un jm un sanner
un jota r pero todo el mundo sabe quién
es ese muro
por eso digo que donald trump es el más
grande muralista del mundo actual
y ni siquiera se va a dar cuenta el
cabrón
yo sé que cuando termine un muro deje de
ser mío se vuelve todos así como el muro
fronterizo
sin saberlo nosotros firmamos las obras
pues cada uno de nosotros somos artistas
de nuestra interpretación cuando es una
obra de arte cuando te gusta cuando no
te gusta cuando l mientas la madre se
vuelve tuya automáticamente ya tiene una
parte de ella en ti y viceversa
cuando nosotros enfocamos nuestra
creatividad en función de las personas y
de los espacios de la ciudad convertimos
el muralismo en una herramienta para
mejorar y transformar nuestra vida
el ingenio colectivo la flexibilidad y
la adaptabilidad de la ciudad hacen que
el ciudadano haga suyo un espacio
el arte que van a plasmar es aquello que
nos une al mundo que nos identifica es
aquello que nos acerca a las personas
desconocidas
esta se une al esfuerzo colectivo por
solucionar retos globales
así como a soñar con nuestro futuro y
bienestar a largo plazo
en todos lados hay muros
porque nos sorprende el muro fronterizo
porque nos la pasamos hablando de esa
madre y hacen renders y hacen crítica
si en todos modos si tú ahorita sales
enojado de aquí con tu esposa
ponerle un muro en medio y no le vas a
hablar como en dos días
y yo creo firmemente que el arte nos une
y a veces aunque no nos demos cuenta
formamos parte de ella
y eso me hace preguntarme si los gringos
están haciendo el muro lo
suficientemente alto como para
mantenernos divididos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]